SPEAKER_00: Good afternoon, Michael. Thanks for coming in today.
SPEAKER_01: Thanks for seeing me. I've been, uh-- I've been really stressed about my taxes lately.
SPEAKER_00: I can imagine. Tax season's coming up fast. So you mentioned on the phone you're making about... what was it... eighty-five thousand this year?
SPEAKER_01: Yeah, eighty-seven actually. Got a raise in June.
SPEAKER_00: Great. So that puts you in the... um... let me think... the thirty-three percent combined bracket here in Ontario. Federal plus provincial. Actually, let me double-check that rate.
SPEAKER_01: Thirty-three percent? That sounds brutal.
SPEAKER_00: Well, marginal rate. Your average tax rate is lower, but yeah, every extra dollar you earn gets hit pretty hard. That's why RRSP contributions are so powerful at your income level.
SPEAKER_01: How much room do I have left?
SPEAKER_00: Good question. Your contribution room is eighteen percent of last year's income, up to the annual limit. So on eighty-seven thousand, that's... um... fifteen thousand six hundred.
SPEAKER_01: But I already contributed eight thousand this year.
SPEAKER_00: Right, so you've got about seven thousand six hundred left. Plus any unused room from previous years. Um, do you have your Notice of Assessment handy?
SPEAKER_01: Yeah, here it is. Says I have... eleven thousand in unused room.
SPEAKER_00: Perfect. So you could contribute up to eighteen thousand six hundred total this year. That would save you... let's see... about six thousand in taxes.
SPEAKER_01: Six thousand? That's huge.
SPEAKER_00: Exactly. Though you want to make sure you have the cash flow to handle that. What's your monthly take-home after deductions?
SPEAKER_01: About fifty-two hundred. Rent's twenty-two hundred.
SPEAKER_00: Okay, so you've got some room. Even if you could do an extra five hundred-- sorry, five hundred a month to your RRSP, that's another six thousand annually. Actually, wait... let me recalculate. Five hundred times twelve is...
SPEAKER_01: Six thousand, yeah.
SPEAKER_00: Right. And at your tax rate, that saves you about two thousand-- two thousand in taxes. Plus the money grows tax-deferred until you retire. What's your current RRSP invested in?
SPEAKER_01: Just sitting in a savings account earning nothing.
SPEAKER_00: Ouch. Even high-interest savings accounts are only paying around four percent now. You're missing out on growth potential.
SPEAKER_01: I don't know much about investing. Seems risky.
SPEAKER_00: I get that. But at thirty-two, you've got over thirty years until retirement. Even conservative portfolios have averaged... what... six to seven percent historically? Let me... I should verify those numbers, but that's, uh, that's about right.
SPEAKER_01: What kind of investments are we talking about?
SPEAKER_00: For RRSPs, I usually recommend a mix. Maybe sixty percent Canadian equity, twenty percent US, ten percent international, ten percent bonds. All through low-cost ETFs.
SPEAKER_01: Canadian equity? Like individual stocks?
SPEAKER_00: No, more like VTI... wait, that's US. For Canada, something like VCN - Vanguard's Total Stock Market Index. Gives you exposure to-- to all the big Canadian companies.
SPEAKER_01: So like Shopify, Royal Bank, that stuff?
SPEAKER_00: Exactly. Royal Bank's been a dividend aristocrat for... what... decades? Shopify's more volatile but good growth potential.
SPEAKER_01: What about my TFSA? I've barely touched that.
SPEAKER_00: That's actually a bigger missed opportunity. TFSA room accumulates from the year you turn eighteen. You're thirty-two, so... um... let me calculate. Six thousand a year since twenty-oh-nine, but the limits changed...
SPEAKER_01: My CRA account says I have forty-three thousand in room.
SPEAKER_00: Wow, okay. So you've barely used it. TFSA is actually better than RRSP for some things because withdrawals are tax-free. No minimum withdrawals either, unlike RRIFs. Or is it RRSPs that convert to RRIFs? I always... I always mix that up.
SPEAKER_01: What should I prioritize - RRSP or TFSA?
SPEAKER_00: Good question. At your income level, RRSP probably makes more sense for the immediate tax break. But TFSA is great for shorter-term goals or if you think you'll be in a higher tax bracket in retirement.
SPEAKER_01: Higher tax bracket in retirement?
SPEAKER_00: Well, if tax rates go up generally, or if you have a good pension plus CPP plus OAS, you might not drop down tax brackets as much as you'd expect. Actually, let me... let me look up current CPP projections.
SPEAKER_01: I don't have a pension at work.
SPEAKER_00: Okay, so you'll rely more on your own savings. That actually tilts toward RRSP being better.
SPEAKER_01: What if I split it? Half RRSP, half TFSA?
SPEAKER_00: That's not a bad hedge. Maybe do the RRSP first for the immediate tax savings, then focus on TFSA. Or do both simultaneously if you can swing it.
SPEAKER_01: How much should I realistically be saving total?
SPEAKER_00: Rule of thumb is ten to fifteen percent of gross income for retirement. On eighty-seven thousand, that's... uh... eight to thirteen thousand annually. You're doing eight in RRSP, so you're at the low end.
SPEAKER_01: Could I bump it to twelve thousand without killing my lifestyle?
SPEAKER_00: That's four thousand more, so about three hundred thirty a month. Sounds doable given your take-home. Would save you another, um, thirteen hundred in taxes.
SPEAKER_01: So I'd net about twenty-seven hundred more savings?
SPEAKER_00: Right, because of the tax refund. It's like the government subsidizing your retirement savings at your tax rate.
SPEAKER_01: When would I get that refund?
SPEAKER_00: If you file in March, probably by May or June. Though you could adjust your payroll deductions to get it throughout the year instead. Actually, let me verify how that works with CRA.
SPEAKER_01: I'd rather just get the lump sum.
SPEAKER_00: Fair enough. Many people prefer that. You could even contribute that refund to next year's RRSP. Creates a nice... a nice cycle - contribution, refund, bigger contribution.
SPEAKER_01: What about timing? Should I wait until the end of the tax year?
SPEAKER_00: Actually no. You have until... um... March first of the following year to contribute for the current tax year. But the sooner you contribute, the more time your money has to grow.
SPEAKER_01: Time in the market versus timing the market?
SPEAKER_00: Exactly. Even if the market drops after you contribute, you've got decades to recover.
SPEAKER_01: What about borrowing to invest in my RRSP?
SPEAKER_00: RRSP loans can make sense if you don't have the cash. Interest rates are around... what... seven percent now? But you get the tax refund to help pay it down.
SPEAKER_01: Sounds risky borrowing to invest.
SPEAKER_00: It's definitely more aggressive. I'd only consider it if you're confident in your job security and can handle the monthly payments even if the market drops.
SPEAKER_01: I think I'll stick to cash contributions.
SPEAKER_00: Probably smart. Building good savings habits is more important than maximizing every dollar. What about other tax strategies?
SPEAKER_01: Like what?
SPEAKER_00: Well, are you claiming all your eligible deductions? Medical expenses, professional dues, union fees if you have them?
SPEAKER_01: I don't think I have much. Maybe dental bills?
SPEAKER_00: Medical expenses are only deductible above... um... three percent of income or... is it twenty-four hundred? Whatever's less. Let me double-check those thresholds for you.
SPEAKER_01: So probably not worth it then.
SPEAKER_00: Probably not. What about charitable donations? Those have better tax treatment - federal and provincial credits.
SPEAKER_01: I donate maybe two hundred to United Way through work.
SPEAKER_00: That'll get you back about... what... sixty to eighty bucks? Not huge, but every bit helps.
SPEAKER_01: What about income splitting with my girlfriend?
SPEAKER_00: Ah, well, you'd need to be married or common-law first. Are you considered common-law? That's usually twelve months living together, but I should... should verify the exact rules.
SPEAKER_01: We've been together three years, living together two.
SPEAKER_00: Then you probably qualify. Income splitting opportunities are limited though - pension splitting, spousal RRSPs. What's her income situation like?
SPEAKER_01: She makes about forty-five thousand, lower tax bracket.
SPEAKER_00: Interesting. You could do spousal RRSP contributions. You get the deduction, but the money's in her name for withdrawl later.
SPEAKER_01: How does that help?
SPEAKER_00: When you both retire, ideally you'd have similar incomes, keeping you both in lower tax brackets instead of you having all the income in a high bracket.
SPEAKER_01: That's pretty far ahead to be planning.
SPEAKER_00: True, but tax planning really is long-term thinking. The decisions you make now compound over decades.
SPEAKER_01: What about investing outside registered accounts?
SPEAKER_00: That gets into capital gains and dividend taxation. Canadian dividends get preferential treatment - dividend tax credit makes them more efficient than interest income.
SPEAKER_01: So Canadian bank stocks?
SPEAKER_00: Could be part of the mix. Royal Bank yields about four percent, but you pay tax on those dividends annually. Capital gains are only taxed when you sell, and only fifty percent is taxable.
SPEAKER_01: Sounds complicated. Maybe I should just focus on registered accounts first.
SPEAKER_00: That's probably smart. Max out your RRSP and TFSA room before worrying about taxable accounts.
SPEAKER_01: How should I actually implement this? All at once?
SPEAKER_00: I'd suggest starting with bumping your monthly RRSP contribution by that three hundred we talked about. Then maybe use your tax refund to contribute to TFSA next year. Baby steps.
SPEAKER_01: And invest it all in those ETFs you mentioned?
SPEAKER_00: Start simple. Maybe a balanced ETF like VBAL - sixty percent stocks, forty percent bonds. Or VGRO if you want more aggressive - eighty-twenty split.
SPEAKER_01: What's the difference in returns?
SPEAKER_00: Historically, more stocks means higher returns but more volatility. VGRO might average eight percent long-term, VBAL maybe seven.
SPEAKER_01: I think I can handle the extra volatility.
SPEAKER_00: At thirty-two, probably. You've got time to ride out the ups and downs. Just don't panic-sell if we hit a bear market. Actually, let me... let me send you some reading on behavioral investing.
SPEAKER_01: This all sounds good. What about fees?
SPEAKER_00: VGRO has an expense ratio of... um... point two five percent, I think? Much cheaper than mutual funds, which can charge two percent or more.
SPEAKER_01: Two percent doesn't sound like much.
SPEAKER_00: Over thirty years, the difference between point two five and two percent fees is... massive. Like, forty percent less wealth at retirement. Fees really compound against you.
SPEAKER_01: Wow, okay, low fees it is.
SPEAKER_00: Exactly. John Bogle used to say 'you get what you don't pay for' in investing. Lower fees mean more money stays in your pocket.
SPEAKER_01: When should we meet again to review progress?
SPEAKER_00: Maybe in six months? That'll give you time to implement the changes and see how the new contribution amounts feel budget-wise.
SPEAKER_01: And you'll send me those ETF details?
SPEAKER_00: Absolutely. I'll put together a summary with the ticker symbols, expense ratios, and a simple implementation plan.
SPEAKER_01: This has been really helpful. I feel less stressed already.
SPEAKER_00: Good! Having a plan makes all the difference. Tax optimization isn't sexy, but it's one of the best returns on investment you can get.
SPEAKER_01: Guaranteed thirty-three percent return on RRSP contributions.
SPEAKER_00: Exactly. Plus the long-term growth. Your future self will thank you for starting now.
SPEAKER_01: Alright, time to adult with my finances.
SPEAKER_00: Ha! That's the spirit. And remember, you don't have to be perfect. Progress over perfection.
SPEAKER_01: Thanks again. I'll be in touch once I get started.
SPEAKER_00: Sounds great. And don't hesitate to call if you have questions. This stuff can be overwhelming at first.
SPEAKER_01: Will do. Have a good rest of your week.
SPEAKER_00: You too. And good luck with the tax optimization!